that man david
nestor cortez
and i guess we could throw the junior on
there i know we used to call him nestor
cortez jr all the time and kind of lost
the junior part but
i'll tell you one thing the guy could
pitch
he's for real mullins great numbers
overall and he is 368 in the first
inning
fly ball left field gallow
one
away ball center field judge comes on
still coming still coming
gets there two way
the o2
swing and a miss
in a happy john means day it is john
means making his 21st start of the
season five and six record with a 3-4
era and i love the strikeout to walk
ratio 104 strikeouts only 19 walks john
means does not beat himself
bounced down to third urias has it one
down
he got him looking
strike on the outside corner at the
knees
one-two pitch he got him down on strikes
here's a 2-2
swung on a high pop in back of first on
the angle le mayhew in foul territory
makes the catch
[Applause]
popped up
and sanchez makes the play
swing and a miss
[Applause]
he swings here and belts it right center
field and deep mullins onto the track
hauls it down in front of the in front
of the bullpen
and he got him breaking ball drops in
for strike three
bounce to the left side jones across
did he go yes he did
swing and a miss mullens down on strikes
two away
every time nestor cortez drops down
you're looking for a breaking ball but
he usually throws fastballs and it's so
effective kind of a crossfire action
with that sidearm release point
one two swing and a miss
[Applause]
a one-two pitch
and it's a ground ball to shortstop
uris has it he slings it to first and no
doors are tired to start the bottom of
the third
bounce to third arias
two down
two two on the way
center field mullen starts back a few
strides in
here's the 2-0
swung on a high fly to shallow right
stanton in toward the line makes the
catch one away
[Applause]
swinging a miss again
that time on a four seamer
first and second orioles looking to get
a base hit with a runner and scoring
position in two outs
soft ground ball gonna have to hurry
odor
gets over the rizzo and that will do it
right field plenty of room santander
drifts back now on the track
yankees without a hit so here is stanton
he struck out in the first inning
high drive into left center field on the
run is mullins on the track looking up
sia a home run for stanton and the
yankees take a one-nothing lead
giancarlo took the shortest easiest
swing you've ever seen
and hit one out in dead left center
field
it is a stantonian home run
giancarlo and no si
stopolo
and down goes jones
so strikeout number seven for quarter
high fly ball shallow left backing up
torres coming in gallow
to the way
grounded to rizzo
flip to cortez
who just beats mullins to the bag for
the final out of a one two three inning
that one's wrapped into center field
it's gonna be base hit
although read it beautifully goes easily
to third the yankees have first and
third and one man out for the top of the
order and le mayhew
that one has driven out to right field
going back santander will make the catch
tagging and scoring easily as odor so
it's a sac fly for la mayhew and it's
two nothing hanks
let's see if they can turn two there's
one
and there's two
two outs nobody on and trey mancini will
bat
and mancini gets into this one into left
field and deep way back there and that
baby's long gone a home run for trey
mancini and it's a 2-1 game in the bronx
and for trey mancini that had to feel
really good for trey his first home run
since august 14.
now aaron judge steps in
ripped and a base hit to left field
cutting overs hayes cuts the ball off in
front of the warning track going for two
as judge
safe he's in there with a double now
here's gleber torres with two outs two
on and two out
fly ball deep center field mullins has
room makes the catch
and cream gets out of the inning what
out nobody on for jorge mateo
high fly ball left field and deep back
back back and we're tied jorge mateo
with his second home run as an oriole
that ball just kept carrying got into
the seats and it's even a two
not had many chances like this tonight
but urias is digging in with hayes good
speed at second and man c the trail
runner at first
that time he doesn't hold up he goes
around
and the orioles will strand too you've
got not only the go ahead run on base
but you have lightning fast speed at
first and now gutierrez
swing and a miss
two-two are scoring ninth inning two
outs mateo at first base representing
the go ahead run now austin wins coming
to
bat swing and a miss
when we go to the bottom of the ninth
inning we're all tied at two
door obviously with the chance to end
the game with one swing of the bat
and down he goes
top half of the tenth inning and now
mount castle coming up peralta ready one
strike pitch on the way
into left field for a base hit mckenna
around third heading for the plate
here comes the throw he slides and he's
in and the orioles have a lead mancini
coming up to the plate 21st home run
came from him earlier
and that one is hit shortly and it's
gonna be a double play
so the yankees put their fastest guy at
second he's the tying run so one away
here is le mayhew
ground ball through for basic here's
santander charging here's the throw home
the players
not in time sliding in with the tying
run it's tyler wade and judge will have
a chance to win this
with two outs and a runner at third
bounce to the right side
mount castle will take it
himself you two runs but they're two
outs
strike three
judge scores the game's over and that's
simple here is stanton
grounded up the middle that's a base hit
here comes judge mullins comes up
throwing and the game is over yankees
win 4-3 a whopped off single by stanton
[Applause]
you